Speaker 1: Donald Trump gave two speeches over the
weekend. One was in Nevada to some volunteers. It
was ridiculous. I'm not even going to cover that.
But I do want to play a couple of clips for you
from Trump's speech in Council Bluffs, Iowa. This
one was particularly glitchy. And as you know,
Donald Trump's brain malfunctions often during
these events, but it actually seems to be getting
even worse. In this clip, you are going to
say Donald Trump, you're going to hear Donald
Trump say that he will deny entry to the United
States, to communists, which he said before, and
I obviously can't possibly do it makes no sense,
almost certainly illegal and impractical. But he
says, I'm going to deny entry to communists and
to Marker's markers. I think he means Marxists,
and he says they won't be allowed into our
country. I didn't misspeak. What I what? I mean,
I did misspeak. But what I mean is Trump says
they won't be allowed into our country. And if
you're watching, you will see Trump do that
glitch he does when his brain malfunctions.
It's very weird and it's getting worse.
Speaker 2: I will also order our government
to deny entry to all communists and Marcus,
like we have Marxists, fascist communists,
they're pouring into our country. We are going
to deny them access to our country now, the one.
Speaker 1: They will not be allowed into our
country. It's just not going to happen. Not if
Trump takes our country back, that's for damn
sure. So that was the most visually ridiculous
moment. But there were also some other I don't
want to say I felt bad, but I almost started
thinking about maybe considering the possibility
of feeling bad. Trump's asked a question here. He
did this thing where he takes questions from the
audience and it's always funny and sad. He's asked
a question about something he has no idea about.
It's related to farmland and pipelines. Trump very
obviously has no clue what this woman is talking
about, and he just kind of says, It's terrible,
isn't it? Well, I have a plan. I have a plan.
No connection to the subject matter whatsoever.
Unidentified: I'd like to know how you can
help us in Iowa to save our farmland from.
Speaker 3: The CO2 pipeline.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah.
Well, you know, we're working on that. And,
you know, we had a plan to totally. It's
such a ridiculous situation, isn't it?
Speaker 1: We had a plan to totally.
To do what? It's ridiculous.
Speaker 2: But we had a plan
and we would have instituted that plan
and it was already. But we will get it
if we win. That's going to be taken care of.
That will be one of the easy things we do.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Hey, how will you fix this
thing? Oh, well, it's terrible. What's going
on? We had a plan. If we win, we're going to do
it very quickly and it's just horrible what's
going on with that. But we have a plan. You know
that, don't you? This is what you say when you
quite literally have no idea what the subject
matter is that you're being asked about. Trump
then made the false claim that in blue states
you can murder children. Okay, listen to this.
Speaker 2: They are the radicals, not the
pro-lifers. They tried to make the pro-lifers
a red. No, no. When they're willing to go
into eight, nine, ten months after birth,
after birth, that was a pass, actually saying
it's okay after birth. They are the radical
ones. And this is an issue, if properly spoken
about. It's because nobody wants to see that.
Speaker 1: It's not happening.
It's not true that states blue
states have legalized killing children.
Speaker 2: After a period of time. Many people
right from the beginning, but nobody nobody wants
to see after four months, five months, six months,
death, termination, nobody wants to see it.
Speaker 1: Okay. So Trump, of course,
just lying about the situation with abortion
rights. And in fact, abortion rights have been
curtailed dramatically as a result of the
overturning of Roe v Wade. We're already
seeing it in a number of different states,
and it's disgusting and horrifying. Lastly,
Trump with a little bit of projection.
He's talking about Joe Biden. But you'd
think that this is actually about Trump, a man.
Speaker 2: We have a president of the United
States who's a stone cold, corrupt. Oh, and.
Well, who is willing to arrest his opponent?
Speaker 1: Okay. Of course, Biden. No involvement
that we know of with the arrest or indictment
of Donald Trump. And if we want to talk about
corruption and criminality, Trump's the guy who
now has, what, 70 charges against him in total
across two indictments. So the typical sort of
greatest hits from Donald Trump struggling to
speak, very low energy speeches in front of
small crowds, the campaign is getting going. And
as bad as this is, the question, of course, is can
anybody beat this guy in the Republican Party? Is
there any appetite at all for something different
than this? Polling suggests the answer is no.
We have new polling. We'll look at it tomorrow.